[Music]
so chuck i haven't checked in on you
lately what's been eating you
well you know i'm not sure if it's
something that's eating me
but i'm curious because a little while
ago you were on cnn
and there was a lot of hoopla about man
returning to space okay no no
billionaire returning that's true
billionaire returns to space
and and actually no it's like this
cro-magnon man
now we have billionaire man this is so
true billionaire man
going there right and and now it looks
like that's the new thing
is that billionaires in space you know
okay
so what's your problem so my problem is
just to be clear i was on i was on
fareed zakaria gps
right to give him a shout out yeah he
was a good guy he's your buddy
that's your buddy um but here's the
thing
so during that day on every single
channel
the coverage was like the moon landing
yeah it was like it was like and i'm
thinking
we interrupt this program right get a
break in
a so i'm thinking like yo
that's kind of like we went to the north
pole
and then we did a sarah pal and
like you know i could see the north pole
from my house
but then we said that was like we went
there didn't we
do better than this already
oh okay so what you mean let me unpack
what you just said so
so on the occasion that i was on cnn
uh it was richard branson right who
had a crew of six including himself who
went into a sub-orbital flight had a few
minutes of weightlessness and then
because it's a space
plane a rocket plane right it could come
back and land on a runway
okay so uh
you're saying did we do that before yeah
kinda we did it
60 years ago with alan shepard
all right america's first astronaut
basically and he was launched from cape
canaveral
launched him due east and plunked down
in his capsule
in the atlantic ocean and we plucked him
out um with an aircraft carrier as we
did with all the
all the astronauts who landed in the
water so we did that 60 years ago
so what why all the buzz because this is
now done by a private
enterprise okay it's called
was it virgin galactic all right so a
private enterprise it's a billionaire
he's on the the jet yeah that's how you
know it was going to work
that's how you knew who's gonna work
that's how you knew it was gonna work
so he has literal skin in the game
and for me i'm not riding any
billionaires
rocket anywhere until they send their
mother and bring her back or
themselves right i mean that this counts
so
this this was remarkable publicity if
you were thinking about signing up for
the trip
and the man gets on the trip himself so
i think all of that worked and the man
likes to live
what's what's the french joie de vivre
whatever however life yeah lover of life
and so
so uh so that was the celebration of the
day
now um so how far did they go
because they kept saying going to the
space space yes
and i'm an astrophysicist i i know what
space
is right all right and they called it
the first commercial space flight
but well except elon has sent his own
spaceships into orbit so and it was
commercial in that sense
so i don't know what they would mean by
that but so so
let's so what do they mean by space well
he went up about 50 miles
something like that around there and
that's lower than the internationally
agreed
altitude by the way just so you know
that's okay the air force recognizes
that as
space but internationally it's a little
higher 62 miles
which comes out to be a clean 100
kilometers so wait a minute you mean to
tell me that
he couldn't tack on 12 lousy miles
it takes a lot more energy to keep
ascending
away from earth's gravity he need a
bigger rock we're gonna need a bigger
rocket
okay you take a look at his size size
his rockets
relative to jeff bezos's rocket that one
is way bigger than the other
just in terms of sort of launch mass
okay somebody's compensating for
something
check i said is chuck gonna go there
yeah
he went there of course chuck went there
so
so so here's the thing so what happens
at 100 kilometers
you ascend high enough so that there's
so few air molecules i think we've
talked about this on a previously
explainer there's so few air molecules
that there's nothing there to scatter
sunlight
and the blue sky sky blue is scattered
sunlight
if you remove the atmosphere because
you're so high up then there's nothing
there to scatter it there is no blue sky
because there's no sky
and then the night time the nighttime
universe reveals itself
while the sun is also in the sky at the
same time
so so they they they classified that as
space the boundary between our
atmosphere and space so if
if you get far enough out of earth
far enough away from earth and you like
yo i think we're in a black neighborhood
you made it to space oh cause the sky
loses this guy literally goes black
i thought you were in therapy for this i
am i
am all right but but anyway
okay and for those of you out there
they're called jokes don't write me and
say
stop being racial chuck you know i live
in america what you want
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so here's the thing okay so
you're in
space that's what we want to call that
space
now you're you're not weightless though
people equate
being in space with being weightless
you're only weightless if you're in free
fall
uh-huh okay so if at that moment he cuts
off his engines
and they fall then you're weightless
gotcha for as long as you're falling
right okay but there's a point where the
atmosphere gets thick enough again
and in the case of richard branson's
rocket it was also an airplane it had
airfoil so right as it starts hitting
atmosphere
then the control surfaces of his wings
begin to
take effect and then it can actually do
a descent
as an airplane but the moment it does
that you are no longer weightless
right okay so i just want to make that
clear the weightlessness is
simply for being in free fall not
for being in what people are calling
space space that's it's not like you hit
space i'm weightless oh my gosh
no no it's are you rockets firing no are
you a plane
no you're just falling you're weightless
over that time it's just like
what is it the parachute drop or
whatever it is at the amusement park
when they just drop the floor out under
you you are weightless until
some parachute opens but over that time
you're weightless
basically weightless okay cool now if
you fall long enough then the air
resists you
all right but for the while you're
accelerating you're weightless and so
that's the experience so now here's the
thing
do you need to go up 62 miles 100
kilometers
to see the night sky no you can just
wait until the sun sets
oh my god that's terrible
i'm just i'm telling like it chuck i'm
just so happy that's why
this is why you you have me as your man
here i am so
i am so happy that neither besos or
branson
are watching this ring
i'm just saying so so to say oh i can
now see the night sky
right i'm in space right after sunset
you're seeing
exactly the same damn night sky okay so
so
so the so then the next side of it is
you're getting to be weightless for a
couple of minutes
well we have what's called the vomit
comet how is this
an airplane without going into space but
it goes to a high enough altitude
and then it just sort of shuts off its
engines and then drops
or there are ways to control it so that
the engines can simulate
a free fall but while in that period
you're weightless
in fact they filmed all of apollo 13
although i was told
all of the weightless scenes in apollo
13 were actually filmed in the vomit
comment
wow so they were actually they're
actually weightless not on on cables
right that that is the level of
commitment that
you have to respect yes yes
yes and so and you only get like 20
minutes of pop so you have to just keep
going you just keep doing that
right to get all your footage right you
can't say oh let's get another take just
for safety no right
that's all you're getting because i'm
ready to throw up all over your ass that
was perfect let's do it again
perfect let's do it again all right so
the night sky you're going to get after
sunset
the weightlessness you can get on a
vomit comet right so
now how high up are they relative to the
earth are they going to see the
curvature
i did a calculation the answer is no
okay
so let's run this back again so chuck
school room globe okay about a foot
across right
right uh the space station okay
you're gonna find that orbiting it'd be
about a centimeter
above this or about three eighths of an
inch that's the
international space station
three-eighths of an inch wow
all right that's 250 mile so so
uh branson went a fifth of that
so it's a fifth of a centimeter that's
two
millimeters which is just
a little less than a sixteenth of an
inch
oh above earth's surface so if you've
got a ruler any standard
like american ruler if it doesn't
doesn't even have
the the more there's no demarcation to
say this is where we are
well because the the first marker is
farther away than the height that uh
richard branson
uh ascended above earth so richard
branson
you must be this tall to ride this rock
sorry buddy stop me no
so i'm just putting out there i'm just
saying i just i i
it's it's truth in in you know
it's we can be honest about it now by
the way if people want to do this
and pay a quarter million dollars i
don't have a problem open up a whole new
tourist industry
no problem no problem oh by the way
jeff bezos's rocket okay you may have
seen
does not land as an airplane because
it's basically a capsule
so that that has to be like retrieved
and brought back
to uh to its destination just the way
alan shepard did in 1961
so but each case there's a period of
time where they are weightless
and that's what people are paying for
and bezos says cabin has bigger windows
so again there is this billionaire
competition thing going on
i kind of i enjoy it on the sidelines
here
it sounds to me the way you have just
described this
is you could save yourself
249
990
by going to six flags
and riding any one of them roller
coasters
okay one one other thing so uh as you
you may remember
there's an airplane that's taking off
that
deploys the rocket plane right and they
go up to like 40 something thousand feet
and the rocket plane takes off all right
the rocket plane is in free fall until
the engines kick in so they'll actually
be weightless for a little period of
time there
and then the rockets kick in and they
experience about three g's
three g's is sort of um
good housekeeping approved g-forces on
the human body
so that's the maximum you're going to
get at an amusement park
that's the what they subject the the
shuttle astronauts to
the uh that so they you they could
accelerate you faster than that
right but they don't need to and so they
don't and so 3gs is like
you know nice um
at at great adventure yeah yeah so so
it's it's within the realm of what we
have all experienced
if you're a fan of amusement parks so
that that's what it is that
wow but but more power to them
somebody's got it i'm glad somebody's
doing it
yeah watch them do it and and that's why
i should put this um i never want to
interfere with someone
who is trying to advance a frontier
right
even if i have skepticism i'll share the
skepticism if you ask what you did
right but i'm not going to run in front
of the line saying don't
not necessarily i just let it go because
there's spin-offs there's all kinds of
things that
overall historically have been good for
civilization
and for culture and so i tip my head to
all of what they're doing
no it's like look you're rich right you
got to find something to do with your
money
somebody comes along and says hey you
like motorcycles right you're like i
love motorcycles they're like i got a
brand new motorcycle for you
it's human powered you get on it and you
just pedal really really hard
and it only costs 250 000 dollars
damn chuck okay by the way elon is not
fooled by any of this
okay because you know you don't hear
elon saying i want to just put people
into sub-orbital paths what is elon
saying
go to mars go tomorrow he's saying go to
mars yeah and and just to put this back
in perspective
so richard branson went two millimeters
above a schoolroom globe
okay uh jeff bezos a little higher okay
the space station is one centimeter
above the globe
the moon 30 feet away okay
mars a mile away oh my goodness there it
is
so on scale yo okay so when you say
let's go into space
right and you tell that to an
astrophysicist i have a different answer
for you
than 50 miles up that's all i'm saying
we got to call it quits there chap
all right why you pull all this out of
me i was perfectly sorry
i was minding my own damn business i'm
so glad we did this though
take that billionaire
[Laughter]
all right uh this has been a star talk
explainer instigated by chuck
neil degrasse tyson here
[Music]